今天就进入我们今天第二个环节呃那首先第一个点就是说因为曹大大家知道是一个比较自身的安卓的方向的救助专家嘛那其实想了解一下就是当初你为什么会选择做安卓呢呃其实一开始做安卓的话是我在上大学的时候啊我是我是15年不是我是一年上了大学然后一年那个时候安卓刚刚新写那个时候我记得还是2.1的系统2.2的系统安卓2.2
然后我当时上大学的时候大家一般情况下的高中考上大学一般都会买个手机对吧然后那个时候我就买了一个安卓的手机那个时候我记得很清楚啊三星的一个安卓手机然后早期的那个安卓界面那个APP很丑包括它的系统那个UI也很丑然后那个时候呢
比较流行的是一个什么就是一个是刷机我刷各种各样的系统miUI就是那个时候起来的比如说我刷这个miUI的系统或者刷一些什么别的系统那个时候又会有很多大神去定制啊去定制系统他们包括有一些已经在像小米这种厂商公司啊很知名的一些大佬叫去定制系统那个时候然后还有就是APP的美化那个时候APP美化干什么事情呢就是
因为那个时候APP签名交易还不是很严格吗就是我可以把一个APP反变异了然后我把里面的什么文案啊什么什么图片也给他换了然后什么颜色什么各种样式给他换了换了以后我在重新打包成一个APP自己装上然后我这个APP不就跟别人找的不一样了吗就这种就当时就是搞这个因为那个时候觉得自己手机太丑了然后发现
社区有那种各种各样的论坛可以刷机让你的系统变得美化然后可以rootroot了以后你就可以把那个厂商的衣衣删掉然后你就可以自己自己装然后还可以搞各种桌面什么三地桌面什么什么那种那种什么立体的就是就是因为这个那时候大家都研究这东西然后我也开始研究这东西我现在自己手机太丑了然后我就开始了解安卓了OK
所以我觉得就那所以你玩安卓切弯的蛮早的等于是那个时候您在做开发了是不是等于是那个时候其实一开始还没有开发只不过那个时候就是说因为那个时候会做一些反变意嘛但是也很简单只是比如说去找一些固定的像像那个那个资源文件的目录啊或者是一些什么
主题的目录图片去做一些替换但那个时候大概会看一下至少你得知道那些文件在哪对吧所以说会对安卓的整体的一个APK里面的一些最表面的那些结构有一个简单的理解然后后面是从大2大3开始那个时候New了一个HelloWord就是那个时候为什么做大家很多情人做前端或者是做移动端那个时候移动端还挺火的然后大家做这个东西
最好的一个就是说我写一个按钮我就能点对吧我就有个反馈不像做后端大学的时候那个时候做后端自己没什么感觉都是迷你好像敲来敲去的然后但是前段不一样他有个UI点一下所以那个时候就开始搞这个安卓开发自己扭了一个HelloWord扭了一个HelloWord以后很有成就感那个按钮可以点击我当时就记得很清楚我当时扭了一个button就是那个最统的那个button然后我在button上面写了个
自己的名字点一下啊有个toast的谈一下我就觉得很牛逼了然后那个时候客户端也很火嘛一下就活起来了叫那个时候大家还叫业界叫mobile first就是什么东西都要搞个app然后是个人创业什么公司都要弄个app然后那个时候就会有很多那种应用比赛就是大家会收集各种各样app的那种创意嘛随时会有那种高效的那个app的应用比赛
然后我那个时候就参加那种比赛其实那种写的一句都很测的很多时候就是网上抄那种代码比如说什么什么根据录制你的声音吹气然后你的那个手机上面就会有你吹吹气吹得越狠你那个火苗就越大什么就是类似于这种其实现在看起来就是很很幼稚的那种小东西但那个时候就就很流行这个然后那个时候就搞这个从这个这个上面入手然后到到大三开始
因为那个时候我只会写个安卓就是会有至少能运行个APP出来然后到大三开始那个时候有一个导师过来找我就他要做一个什么项目他那个时候做一个项目是有一部分是要在手机端上面做的然后那个项目是什么东西就是说他的一个假设一个场景就是当发生地震的时候
就是这种灾害的时候,往往是突然发生了嘛然后一般情况下人离自己的手机都不远对吧比如说我突然被埋了或者说我被埋了这个地方至少我还能能用我这个手机就是移动设备还在工作那么这个时候当搜救人员到现场的时候能不能第一时间先利用广大埋在下面的人的这个移动设备去进行初步的定位和最
初步的搜究环节抓住黄金72小时嘛当时就是这个东西然后我觉得很有意思我说那行我说我做安卓可以然后我那时候就开始研究这个东西了就是在这个项目里面做安卓那个时候就搞比如说什么通信协议啊什么什么蓝牙什么网络而且那个时候还会搞那个alhoc网络其实LS大家对alhoc可能可说安卓其实大家可能没怎么听过就是用自足网络就在没有wifi的情况下我怎么样去把
大家的手机连在一起然后还要有数据的传递然后还要什么就是去判断有一个路线出来判断什么我该救哪个人救哪个人就是这么一个模型然后当时就搞这个从大三搞到毕业毕社也做了就是就像一直延展到我毕业做完毕业设计所以说这就是安卓在在我上学的时候的一个一个新入历程然后就胜利成当的毕业就
一直做安卓到现在哦明白所以其实我觉得是首先第一个点可能是源于兴趣对吧对兴趣做了一个很重要的一个引导然后另外其实也是因为在刚好在那个时候有这样的一个确实是移动到那热炒吧然后有这样的一个机会而且应该是一个比较有意思的项目让你选择了去做安卓这样的一个方向对是的因为那个时候有很多正向反馈你做完了以后立马就能收获一定成就感然后你就可以坚持下去明白明白对ok
好的那其实到现在其实已经现在你也是专家了嘛对然后想了解一下就是在这个过程中啊因为其实从新手开放点到专家其实还是有很长的一段路的想了解一下就是你在这个过程中啊到底今年的一些阶段然后你觉得这每个阶段比较重要的是什么对其实最开始我从这个就是刚从学校出来的时候那个时候15年毕业的
然后15年毕业我拿着我刚才的那一波项目我那一波项目有一部分代码还在Gatehub上我自己Gatehub还开源了然后我就拿着我那个项目就那个时候面试到处乱杀就是offer随便拿什么大厂过来都可以都被我项目挣住了那个时候什么什么阿里什么腾运都随便乱杀就是收割机然后那个时候就是新手开发者刚刚出校门的时候觉得自己老牛逼了觉得自己太强了可强了强了不行然后
那个时候呢我是去了当时去俄罗蒙实习我只在俄罗蒙实习过采机应该知道这个就是一定渊源的对吧然后我当时在俄罗蒙实习的时候呢那个时候俄罗蒙还是C轮啊刚达到C轮的融资啊然后那个时候互联网给我的感觉是卧槽怎么说呢就是就是我大家都太太这行业太有钱啊就那个时候我们团建都是
没有没有上线随便花钱就是指的那种感觉然后大家都配最好的那种什么工程椅搞什么键盘什么哇随便买的那种随便报销然后当时我就在俄罗门然后俄罗门那个时候是精精强降政策就是说要用最少的开发做最牛逼的APP当时这么搞的然后那个时候俄罗门特别火然后我就去俄罗门实习然后我就俄罗门实习以后
当时带我的人对吧那现在也是很有渊源的了啊然后那个时候在恶能么就开始觉得自己特别牛逼就敢做各种各样的事情因为觉得自己很强嘛然后那个时候就就做了就一开始在恶能么我经历里面写的就是做RNG落地那个时候reignative才0.1G的版本就什么文档都没有就是凸的然后那个时候大家根本不知道这玩意怎么落地啊写个UI写个demo会但是在工程里面怎么用不知道
然后我当时就开始学习前端的那一套东西我刚刚是个安卓嘛然后我就可以学习前端那些东西因为我那个时候刚毕业那个时候研究过那个可多吧就是以前的分gap啊内耗直接sdmi打包壳子的东西然后我当时就搞然后就去搞RNRN然后就研究那个当时做封鸟现在也在用就是大家都在用的那个封鸟APP啊然后我在里我们在里面在RN落地哇那个时候我觉得我我太强了我等等把那个东西搞下来然后搞下来了以后我还敢给
然后那个时候觉得自己非常强,那是从新手开发者到出来的第一个阶段觉得自己无所不能然后后面呢
随着不断的经历各种各样的项目对吧接触各种各样的人然后学习发现哎呀自己当初太盲目自信了然后觉得我自己什么也不会当初做的都是什么东西啊只了解最皮毛的那一点点能运就是代码能跑就感觉好像什么都会了但实际上差得太远了那个时候就说我那个时候有一段经历是我去了美团以后
在美团端的核心基础架构就是整个集团的中间舰团队然后当时美团大家都知道肯定会看美团技术博客那个技术博客知名度是非常非常高的粉丝也很多而且那个时候美团是在移动端投入
很大的一家公司有点像现在的自己然后那个时候美团会研究各种各样的移动端的这种核心的这种技术然后我们当时在里面就做嘛那个时候我觉得我刚去的时候我看了同事的代码就是每一行我都我那个单词知道什么意思啊拼成代码我就太理解了然后那个一行代码什么意思可能拼成方法我就太理解了我就觉得自己什么都不会什么都要学这就是第二个阶段就是就是感觉一开始就是就像那个
一开始曲线就是先上升啊飞到一个顶点我一下就跌到谷底了然后跌到谷底了以后呢然后那段时间就开始慢慢磨嘛就开始慢慢学嘛就问人家呗为什么代码这么写就开始积累各种各样的经验然后也有很好的项目和机会去立点去解决一些真正比较难的问题然后从这个阶段之后才是有一个慢慢爬坡的一个
就是知道自己大概能解决什么问题就是知道自己的底在哪水平大概是一个什么样的水位然后到现在就是慢慢慢慢从美团出来以后爬到现在经历的阶段就是一个曲线缓慢上涨的一个过程就是慢慢的对这个不管是对业界同行包括对自己包括对这个业界知名的各个公司各个团队之间做的事情自己做的事情有一个
客观的评估然后做一个事情的话呢也知道自己能做到什么程度然后呢也知道业界的一个整体是什么程度有哪些方案我可以去选行然后我要怎么做就是工具库会很丰富然后经验也会有一定的激烈就是一个慢慢爬坡的过程其实就是经历了这几个阶段比较比较大的一个变化就是这几个阶段我能理解就是其实可能它是一个
做加法和做减法的过程对吧呃就是我说这个加法和减法可能就是说在前期的时候是加的是一些就是就经常讲我们可能就讲无知者无畏嘛对是的可能在前期的时候可能什么都不懂反而觉得哎自己好像很厉害然后到了一个阶段之后就开始觉得哎可能要把自己这些东西该突然看到一个更大的世界了对吧然后又减一减然后再慢慢的再去一个就是一个平稳的方式去做一些积累
对OK这个也蛮有意思因为我们之前其实这个问题也问过别的别的这种别的一些那个加那个讲师嘛他们给的可能也不太一样就你这个还蛮特别的就这个过程是一个不同的是而且我中间正好经历了一段那个科普段的那种百花齐放技术方案的爆发期那个时候动态化方案层层出不穷大家现在看到的这种动态化的层出的方案都是那个时候诞生过来嗯
明白,可以的,可以的。然后我觉得因为刚才草达其实讲了很多这种各方面的技术嘛,包括尤其是像这种跨端的技术。然后其实我特别想聊一下,因为我之前也看草达做过一些codding方向,比如说那个叫K,是KMM是吧?对,对,对,对一些分享。我想了解一下就codding这个语言,就在不够他整个技术的maps中是一个什么的定位啊。
其实coldling最开始它的定位是在安卓上面能一定程度上替代掉java就是在安卓上面的它的语言是在我觉得是16还是17年Google IO上面它说了一个叫coldling first就是说在安卓上面首许的语言从java变成coldling开发那么
随即谷歌后面就推出了安卓的开发工具包叫Jetpack组件,Jetpack组件库,Jetpack组件库里面还有很多东西,比如说LeaveCycle,LeaveData,包括各种各样的,比如说像Room,这种DP的组件,包括什么Navigation,导航的组件,它都是用codling开发的。
然后呢Google呢安卓就是我们正常像iOS有Foundation这种库对吧安卓的那个类似于Foundation的库就是我们的support包比如说我们的activity什么这些类都在那里面然后support包呢在更新到28这个版本以后呢就不更新了那Google呢Google呢把它全面前移成了安卓X就是安卓X然后呢这个里面呢它就用codling去实现这个
什么activity啊什么fragmented这些东西了所以说从框架层面framework层面呢就去往这个方向转所以说这个对于安卓的影响很大所以说后面安卓开发现在安卓开发基本上都是会codling的所以他是从这个方向出来然后在这个他是其实我理解就是安卓安卓把他带火了嘛因为其实本来没有其他的人一定要用codling就是安卓开始搞codling first然后然后后面那个codling呢就
就大放异彩了嘛就很多开发者去用他然后发现了他的比如说那个他的Option他的那个语法堂他可以没有NPE对吧防止NPE等等他的那个经验的语法堂他的各种各样的特性所以就然后呢他又会用在各种地方比如说像后端因为Cortlin他跟Java基本上不像RS跟Swift跟OC那么大的隔阂他基本上可以无缝的嘛所以也会用在后端然后包括Cortlin也就是
其实Cortlin早在18年就开始做Cortlin Native了171年就有了那个时候叫Cortlin Native用Cortlin写像我们现在写C++的SO库一样用Cortlin写真正Native的库然后去做跨平台然后这个是Cortlin语言的本身的特性Cortlin在设计的时候它就是一个跨平台的设计它本身现在包括后面眼镜成了Multiplatform这个project它其实就是
利用了culturing语言本身的跨平台的特性去编一层各种各种各种各样平台的产物嘛然后本身也是用culturing自己的语言去实现的所以现在的所以说从从安卓这个这个域整个出发culturing first到现在扩大到了各种各样的域然后包括其实现在也有很多包括前两天我还看了那个qcon
InfoQ的投销文章Mata就是Facebook把它的APP全部用就是开始大面积的用Codling重写然后包括安卓上面这个举示文明的对吧我们都用的OK HTTP什么包括所有安卓几乎都会用的Leap Canary什么Retrofit这种库其实很多知名的世界知名的开源项目都在用Codling重写而且很多都已经用Codling重写完了所以就是在
整个现在就靠近身体整个发展起来我觉得大概就是这么一个定位然后我后面还是挺看好这个靠近包括它的语言本身的一个眼镜和这个跨单方向的而且你会了这个语言以后其实包括现在自己也应该是有用靠近在写后端的就是会相对来说激进一点明白我觉得对于安卓开发来说靠近肯定是一个就像就像阿尔斯开发学Civus肯定是一个不需要学的东西是的
我觉得而且我觉得早接触肯定比晚接触要好对没错 而且现在很多尤其是外企你在面试安卓这个岗位的时候他都会要求你有靠这里面的这个基础是是是ok ok 好的谢谢曹达的解答ok 然后另外还有一个就是因为曹达最近做了很多分享所以我们还想了解一下
就是因为你之前好像有专门做了一个分享去讲怎么样去做一个比较好的技术分享当然我觉得可能没有那么多时间让你去专门去讲但我觉得你可以大概比如说提炼一下可能有几个部分是你觉得对于提高这个分享技巧比较重要的给大家分享一下分享分享技巧的话其实我觉得这个提高自己的分享技巧首先要锻炼思维也就是你分享的本质是你要把你想讲的东西
讲给别人听然后你的希望是让别人听完你讲的东西以后能达到跟你近似的理解这个是你最希望的所以说就是要锻炼思维很多人面临一个问题是我可能我这个东西做得很不错但是我这个嘴一说说出来别人又会觉得一个是听不懂没有什么头绪然后再一个就是觉得你这个东西也没有什么值得我学习的我也没有什么可急的甚至有些觉得很low就讲的不好
所以这个时候首先就是要锻炼你的思维怎么样锻炼思维我觉得最好的方式是写文章因为这个成本很低就是大家在做技术的过程中总会做一些总结很多人其实都是很愿意去写这个技术文章的那么在写文章的时候呢其实有些很多文章我看了就是类似于流水帐嘛但是其实在你大家如果说真的想锻炼的话呢你在写文章的时候要有意识的去锻炼组织你这个文章的语言和思维
一方面呢在你写的过程中呢其实你一方面是你文章写的越好大家愿意看然后看了以后有更多的这个收获对你也是一个正向的反馈第二个就是说在你不断的写文章优化自己的这个思维的过程中你也能有更好的比如说结构化的思维抽象的思维然后你有对比如说你要讲一个技术方案你是要有一个
比如说有一个设计的理念你把这个东西展示给大家然后你中间有哪些核心的模块最终你是怎么样把它构建什么一个方案然后怎么样变成一个解决方案怎么样运用在线上落地最终你取得了什么样的收益这都是一系列这种技术类分享的一种模板或者是一种思路你把它锻炼出来以后其实你的文章写的也会很好然后你的分享也会很好
那这是结构化思维的一个锻炼还有一个就是提到分享这个事情因为你不只是写文章还有种就是你要嘴说嘛那这个就是要锻炼你演讲的技巧就是有些人他可能就是东西写的很好但是你让他讲他可能会讲不出来比如说在这么多人面前他没有自信或者说声音很小而接接巴巴等等一系列原因导致他讲的效果很不好那
这个分享的一部分除了写文章锻炼好的思维之后就是演讲那演讲的话呢其实像我们很多都是用PPT的这种方式去展示你的内容那PPT呢它不可能像文章一样那么多字对吧让大家一点点看而是需要你核心的进行一个抽象把你抽象出来的模型对吧展示在上面然后呢你再去做详细的解释然后你的PPT之间要有连贯性对吧你要把
让大家在一夜一夜看了过程中从问题的带入到问题的解决到最后的总结和展望你这个思路要能串起来那这个就是你的演讲技巧和准备演讲污料的一个能力那这也是分享在你文章这块色为锻炼好的之后的下一个环节然后最后呢就是说想锻炼分享技巧一定要做到严谨就是我说的严谨就是说比如说一些什么像错别字啊像语句不通病句
甚至是标点符号不对等等这一系列都是需要注意的这个也是我当时在美团的时候因为那个时候大家都很想在那个美团技术博客那个公众号上发文章然后发文章的时候当时是那个审核是非常演的精确到了标点就那个时候我才知道很多标点符号到底要怎么用以前其实都是随便一些
但那个时候学习到了很多标点符号到底应该怎么用在什么场景所以这个也是严谨如果说你的这个内容做的严谨会让大家感觉你的产出的内容非常专业让大家感觉你的内容很专业他也更愿意去阅读这就是提高分享技巧我觉得几个核心的点OK好的谢谢曹大的解答
我觉得这个应该是很精华的因为上一次我记得曹达应该讲了很长一段时间对上次是访谈了行什么聊了一个半小时对对对对对所以我觉得这个应该是很精华的部分大家一定要记住ok那还有就是第五个问题啊就是因为其实我们知道曹达其实在应该是在圈内啊其实应该是有很好的个人的纪录品牌的当然大家也了解就现在其实工作强度应该都不小对吧我也觉得在阿里工作强度也不很小所以想了解一下就是在这种强度的
工作情况下你是怎么样去建立自己的技术品牌的呢其实这个我觉得其实跟上一个问题有一定的相似度就是你要想建立技术品牌的前提是你要有内容就是你要有物料嘛然后一个品牌怎么形成就是一个是你要先有物料第二个就是你要运营第三个就是你要让大家看到你让大家看到了以后才有可能形成品牌所以说第一个部分是准备物料
准备物料的话呢就是我觉得最好的方式还就是写文章这个我也给很多同学讲过你的文章就是你最基础的物料你准备好了这些以后呢第二个部分就是你要怎么样把你的文章展示给别人看那前提这有两种方式一种是对量就是很多的文章你看他写的特别多几百篇一天一两篇的那种写他是靠量取身但是有一部分人他是靠质就是可比如说看他一个月两个月才写一篇
但是这一篇文章的值得反复细读我我个人是其实更推荐这种按制的方式去去做的因为你一篇很好的文章可以立马出圈就是大家会看到你这个里面真的有有东西啊有收获确实好值得反复品读了这种所以这个这个也是因为之前在美团包括
在恶了么的时候都有锻炼嘛就是那个时候大家还是很愿意去发文章的然后大家那个时候其实想的都是以秩序取胜嘛所以我觉得就是锻炼好你思维写好你的文章然后这个时候你有文章在手你
解决了你就是你把你真正工作中的内容去抽象出来其实这个是很难的写一篇优质的文章是很难的你首先分析出什么东西优质然后你在工作中比如说你遇到的什么问题你要能把它抽象出一个通用的模型你的技术方案各个方面都有你的思考在里面的一个文章是能看出一个人的思考然后你把这个东西准备好了以后你就可以去运营了运营的话其实最最最正普通的话就是我加微信询对吧
那时候大家肯定会拉群我觉得群里面发一下你看我解决了这个问题有没有同学有类似的可以一起交流一下那这种情况下大家看了你的文章觉得你写得很棒那这种次数这种就是不断的一个叫什么就是训练嘛不断的一个就有点像那个那个那个那个那个那个机器学习训练一下对吧你一个数据级你不断的去喂喂喂然后这个时候大家就会觉得就会对你有一个印象就是你这个人写的文章不错
你这边写的文章我觉得品质都很好可能我没看过我也很认可然后呢那在这个运营手段上面一方面是你可以有各种社群再一方面就是你可以比如说投稿投到一些像比如说像老司机公众号这种很出名的这种公众号上面他帮你发因为很多公众号都是希望投稿的因为他内容可能不会有那么多但是他希望能有
有一些高质量的投稿能保持它的功耗更新对吧那这个时候其实也是一种宣传个人的方式然后然后就是分享如果说你解决的问题确实足够有难度或者有通用性或者有行业的前瞻性那么你就可以去比如说去联系或者去申请或者是本来各种方式吧你去能在这种会议上面不管是小的分享会议还是大的分享会议你去演讲
更让更多的人明白你的方案在说什么其实大家要的是其实可能很多人要的是我从你的这个方案里面我学到了一种思路你给了我一种启发那这种的话你的这个就是受众就会更广那其实这种就是慢慢慢慢建立所谓品牌的一个过程那核心就是让更多的人认识你然后觉得你东西写的不错然后你确实写的也不错那这样的话不断的迭代一下
不斷地規不斷地規就有点像这种感觉然后慢慢就会变成这个样子嗯我觉得从曹大讲这个问题我觉得就能看出来曹大是一个有很有结构化思维的人因为你在讲这个过程的时候我其实在老海中就有一张就那样的一个图了对吧比如说你的内容是作为一切东西的基础然后你在这个内容之上呢去建立了你的整个去运营的一个机制对吧然后在这个运营过程中可能还有一些层级和递进的关系
所以我觉得这个结构是确实在脑海中是一张图的我觉得这个也是个比较精华的一些部分大家可以就如果说也想建立自己的个人纪录品牌的话我觉得曹大奖这个路应该是非常非常不错的一条路应该也是效率最高的一条路大家可以学习一下还有点就是一定要有自信当你去写文章真正发表别人看的时候那个时候要对自己产出的内容有自信
至少認為它是不差的它是比較優質的明白這個資訊要有ok好的ok那我們現在看一下下一個問題吧就是可能大家就是剛才我們聊的可能很多是跟曹大本身自身相關的嘛那其實有一個就是講一下團隊相關的比如說曹大現在在1688嘛那你們是怎麼去建立這樣的一個技術氛圍的呢其實建設技術氛圍的話呢我們就是有各種各樣的一部分是活動
就是比如说什么程序员节啊这种包括一些平时的一些大家会有一些各种小活动什么小沙龙我们那边有种小沙龙然后又就是针对新人的小培训那这种帮助大家比如老代心啊等等这一系列方式师兄弟啊这种帮助大家去成长建设一个技术氛围还有种就是一些激励比如说比如说有些人他很辛苦他这段时间他他解决了很多大家看不见的问题
但又是用户体验的问题那这种情况下呢我们会有一个微光项目就是能让微小的光也能让被大家看见就是能让更多的人做的东西不只是在阴影之下而是能在聚光灯下也能让大家看见因为不是所有人的东西都会在聚光灯下对吧但是其实大家的成长都是需要有一定正向激励的所以说我们会有很多包括我们也会每个
每个S会有这种评奖就是比如我们有什么守门员奖有那个什么青囊享受奖你就经常给大家做分享青囊享受对吧没有那种青马奖就是你你写了代码你的这个CR你的代码值当很高啊这种都会有各个方面的激励通过各种这种手段去帮助大家就是帮助整个团队形成一种就是比较正向的技术氛围
对 我们这样讲的就是因为我其实也做了很长时间的纪录社区嘛 我们竟然会讲也会讲就是一个团队其实它是有两个部分的就是我们讲技术技术我们将讲技术文化建设就是可能会讲两个一个是纪录氛围 还有一个是纪录品牌嘛对这个技术氛围其实理论上应该是一个团队的核心的原屈动力
记录品牌其实是说可能有这个品牌之后就是这个平台会对更多的人知道那可能会有更多人愿意加入到这个平台那它其实这个氛围和平台是相辅相成的一个过程对吧对所以我觉得像曹大奖就1688其实核心的就是第一个就是传承嘛我们用传承的方式去建立一个比较好的这种技术的传递的就是氛围的传递机制然后另外还最主要就是基地
我们有足够好的或者是足够这种细化的细分的这种这种激励手段能让大家去在各个领域去发光发热这有点事OK然后其实我理解就是本身这些氛围建设是我们的也会有一些对外的产出对不对同时就是让大家对整个1688的这个纪录舱内的品牌能有个更好的认知那可能就会吸引更多对这个就是有技术追求的人进入到这个团队然后就把这个团氛围又做得更好
对吧就是一个长期的过程对因为我发现这个东西其实很多团队都是这样的它其实通过品牌和氛围相互的这种一个是对外一个是对内然后相互的基地去产生一个正向的一个循环对好的我觉得这种经验的话像比如说今天直播间如果有这种带团队带团队的同学其实是可以学习一下的可以在自己团队里面如果想去建设这种
氛围和品牌的话我觉得是可以去参考一下行那我再问一下就是因为现在可能直播间有一些同学也得越来越把他赶进去嘛那想看一下就是我们会比较看重后者人的一个什么品质呢其实两个方面一方面就是你的硬的东西就是你的自己的本身的一个能力那就是一个基础的一个技术的能力然后就是你的工程的素养技术的素养那这个还有就是你核心的一个学习的能力因为其实
我这两年也做了很多分享大家也可以看得到就是整个技术方案包括端的一个架构都是在一个不断眼睛的过程中的你是肯定要有一定的学习和理解的能力你才能跟着这个东西一直往前走自己也往前眼睛所以说学习能力也很关键核心的技术能力基础的能力还有就是学习能力这个就是硬红火这方面这是最Base的还有就是软实力就是说
因为你单兵作战的能力肯定是有限的你一个人再扭你一个人写的代码一天也不可能写一万毫你肯定是有一定限度的那这个时候我们会看你的这个沟通协作举行员的能力跟大家怎么去合作你怎么把这个项目一个大的项目能把它弄起来不是你一个人你可能好几个人一起做对吧你怎么通过各种协同的方式
能达到一个比较大的目标能把一个大的东西拆解成各个小的然后大家各自分布去实现最终组合形成一个大的方案这个就是比较软实力沟通协作甚至可能会有一些项目管理等等这一方面的这个能力这个其实能把沟通协作做好的人不是很多但是能做好的人他是能承担更大的责任他会有更广的欲去做
甚至是带一个团队去做事情好的那我觉得今天可能应该是最后一个问题了就是因为曹达作为一个安卓的现在一个安卓的方面的专家然后其实大家现在可能对于整个行业也不是说特别的怎么说呢就是现在这个互联网这个行业大家肯定不是特别有信心对所以想了解一下比如说像曹达你说作为安卓开发觉得后续
怎么去发展会比较好一点我觉得是这样就是其实这个也拓宽一点就是比如说我作为一个不管是安卓还是LS我作为一个客户端的开发甚至是我作为一个前端的开发我后面该怎么发展那现在大家客观意识到了就是大环境不好对吧其实那这种情况下呢我的建议是呃大家可以选择首先根据自己的一个特点
我是想选择在某一个方面深入研究还是希望我能够在上层横向做得更宽这里面就是两种类型的人一种是基础深度型的人才一种是基础架构类的人才还有一种就是我贴合业务做业务解决方案的人才比如说我基础深度的人才就是比如说我解决一个因为像安卓开发不管是安卓还是iOS开发
它有很多很深的領域那我解決這一個領域的業界難題那這就是我不可替代的一個因素那這是一個方向但這個方向其實比較窄一個公司其實一方面是只有基本上頂尖的公司才會有這個能力才會有這個訴求那再一個就是頂尖的公司呢他這方面做這方面的人也不多然後還有一種就是
技术架构性的人才 架构性的人才就是说我怎么样去在支撑业务 就是我的核心目的是为了支撑业务那我怎么样去做架构的眼镜 架构的收敛 对吧我怎么样去更好了支撑业务 怎么样去提升整体的我们团队的一个研发效能包括怎么样把架构推向未来 往未来去眼镜做一些未来的探索 这个就是技术架构性的人才那还有种就是业务架构性的人才就是说
跟业务走在一起比如说不管我是一个Android我是一个前单我是一个iOS但是可能比如说我负责或者说我当前正在做的是用增的业务那我可能要要负责的就是说我需要通过我的技术手段我的技术工具能让用户增长能增强一个是增长一个是留存对吧这是我的一个业务目标那就是说我从业务目标拆解出来我的技术方案
然后通过我自己会的这个技术方案它可能不一定很深或者很难但是我能通过各种各样的方案的组合最终达到业务目标的一个提升这个就是说跟业务走在一起在比如说是做业务解决方案或者业务架构的这种业务性的人才那这也是一个发展方向而且这个方向现在其实能做好的人不多很多人其实大家觉得做业务就
就就技术很菜的那种感觉啊就觉得做架构很牛逼其实不是其实你要真能把这个业务这种解决方案做好你在这个域能在配合应的业务理解和你对技术本身的一个理解那这就是一个符合性人才这种人才也是比较难得的然后呢就是
还有种就是大家刚才不是很多人都提到我们转行转行吗?那转行的话呢我是不建议你直接break change的那种转行比如说我突然转过去了这种其实你之前的积累很多经验会浪费掉我的建议呢就是说如果你想去探索更多的话你要基于当前自己的这个比如说端上那端上的话假设我去往一个方向去转型假设我现在想想去蹭一下热点对吧
去搞搞元宇宙那我可能搞搞啊我去搞搞3D模型对吧我基于端上现在其实很多这个APP比如说像QQ啊什么的天猫啊都会有我把什么优异做个裁检对吧集成到端里面来哎我就可以渲染模型了我就可以去搞那个那个那个小游戏啊这些东西这个其实也是一种发展路线就是说我在当前的域内我觉得没有自己自己没有什么特特别大的这种特长然后呢我也
不是那种非常理也有的人我就去探索新的方向对吧那我去去别的赛道嘛就是我这个赛道已经人满为患了卷不过了太急了我换一条人少一点的赛道创新点的赛道我再去探索这也是一种发展的路子好的好的谢谢曹达的解答那我们今天活动的话应该到这里差不多就结束了OK